ومعنا الان من غلاف غزه مراسلتنا نجوان
السمري كالعاده نقف في راس كل ساعه على
المستجدات تفضلي
نجوان نعم بالفعل ليلى وهناك تفصيل اكثر
حول مقتل الجنود والضباط التسعه في معارك
يوم امس والتي اعلن عنها في الساعه
الاخيره من قبل الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
عمليا تسعه قتلوا في الساعات ال 24 ال
الماضيه في احداث مختلفه سته من بين
الجنود والضباط القتلى قتلوا جراء انفجار
ل لشاحنه كانت تحمل مواد متفجره بحسب ما
رشح كانت معده لتفجير احد الانفاق في
منطقه جبل في منطقه مخيم البريج وا تفجرت
الش الشاحنه في ذلك الموقع لكن حتى الان
لم يتضح فيما اذا كانت قد استهدفت من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهذا ما ادى الى
انفجارها ام ان خلل معين وقع وفقا لتلميع
بطبيعه الحال من بعض المصادر العسكريه بان
الانفجار داخلي لكن حتى الان لم يتم
الاعلان كيف حدثت عمليه التفجير وعندما
نتحدث عن سته من الجنود والضباط فهم من
سلاح الهندسه
في الجيش الاسرائيلي الذين يقومون بعمليات
التفجير للمباني والمنشات والابراج التي
نراها كثيرا في مقاطع الفيديو التي ينشرها
بانفسهم الضباط والجيش لتفجير هذه المنشات
وهذه المباني لى لكن اربعه منهم من وحده
يهلا وهي وحده نخبه في سلاح الهندسه توكل
اليهم عاده هم ومن قوات الكوماندوز ايضا
المهمات الخا خاصه اذا اربعه من بين السته
الذين قتلوا في الانفجار في الشاحنه التي
كانت تحوي مواد متفجره هم من وحده يهل
وحده النخبه كما تسمى في الجيش الاسرائيلي
احد الجنود القتلى قتل في اشتباك مسلح في
منطقه خان يونس جراء استهدافه من قبل احد
المقاومين
الفلسطينيين واثنان اخران قتل جراء اطلاق
صاروخ مضاد للدروع على واحده من مدرعات
واليات الجيش ايضا في منطقه خان يونس اذا
هذه هي الحصيله لعدد القتلى وال القتلى
الجنود
والضباط في الجيش الاسرائيلي خلال ال 24
الماضيه بالاضافه ايضا الى عدد من
الاصابات بعد قليل سيتم تحديث عدد
الاصابات في اليوم الاخير من قبل الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي ولكن هنا ايضا نشي
ونؤكد انه عاده يكون هناك فجوه بين ما يتم
نشره من قبل الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
بخصوص عدد الجرحى تحديدا وبين ما تنقله
وتنشره المستشفيات الاسرائيليه التي تقدم
العلاج لهؤلاء الجنود الذين ينقلون من ارض
المعارك في غزه تحديدا مستشفى
ع بئر السبع سوروكا و برزيلاي في عسقلان
هذه هي المستشفيات التي استقبلت وقدمت
العلاج لاكبر عدد من الجنود ولو نظرنا فقط
الى المعطى الذي تتحدث عنه مستشفى سوروكا
في بئر السبع فعندما تتحدث عن مجمل
الاصابات التي تعاملت معها منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب فهي اكثر من عدد الاصابات التي
يتحدث عنها الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب فقط مستشفى واحد وهناك عدد اخر
من المستشفيات الذين التي استقبلت هؤلاء
الجنود وبالتالي مزيد من القتلى مزيد من
الجرحى بين صفوف جنود جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهذا ما تحدث عنه تماما هذا
اليوم ناح برنيه احد ابرز الكتاب
والمحللين في صحيفه دعوت عندما قال كيف
يمكن ان نخرج من هذا البئر الذي دخلنا
اليه في هذه الحرب وا عدم السماح لمزيد من
القتلى والجرحى بين صفوف الجيش بالتصاعد
بطبيعه الحال ليلى هذا بلا شك احد الاسئله
التي سيتم مناقشتها مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الذي يزور تل ابيب حاليا على
العموم اشكرك جزيلا نجوان سمري على هذه
التفاصيل المهمه شكرا جزيلا